avant que joue la boîte à pouilly
j'aimerais que chacun d'entre vous
nous dise
si
il a un très très gros dossier qui n'a
jamais mis dans la boîte à pour qu'ils
jouent pas savoir quoi si oui sur qui
mais sans donner le dossier et on ne
donnera jamais jamais d'accord peut-être
pour une spéciale un gros prize ce sera
bien entendu la fin du fin de castaldi
ouais j'ai un énorme dessus sur qui
sur guillaume jan tour pardon sur
guillaume genton bon on peut le donner
tout une
[Rires]
énorme énorme qui révèle à la fois son
comportement sa psychologie ses goûts ah
oui à quel niveau les gouffres à ses
goûts sexuels voilà non pas forcément
mais c'était dans abbaoui m'a dit que
maintenant non non non vous plaît s'il
vous plaît aux respecte un jour je crois
que kelly a
mangé toutes les infos tout le monde au
calme et vous deux
valérie benaïm oui j'ai un énorme match
j'en ai même plusieurs sur la même
personne sur qui sur vous a
beaucoup de dossiers sur moi oui
quelques-uns benhaim faites attention à
vous
j'aimerais pas qui vous arrivent à
l'heure
17h10
les cliniques de la terre et vous allez
vous pouvez révélé quand vous voulez oui
je suis droit dans mes bottes il
j'ai un très gros dossier sérieux et
j'aimerais bien les jours le balancer
sur benji balancer le match ben on a dit
qu'on ne ferait pas une autre fois web
alors je vais peut-être changer les
règles je répondrai pas sur moi qui dis
ouais c'est un énorme dossier sur
raymond non ils étaient
des milliers à big wheel après vous
donner des indices à les y
attend
j'aime bien pour la cohésion du groupe
je peux dire
fétichiste
fétichiste moitié
ça doivent en effet rugby zar dans son
tube séparément bas merci tu regardé
j'ai un énorme dossier qui pourrait
mettre fin à la carrière d'un
chroniqueur
dites moi qui suis je vous dis je
montiel
j'y vais ce que ça mettrait pas vraiment
à sa carrière définitivement
écouter en justice ce serait de
l'escroquerie et du recel ici ce serait
du foutage de gueule
non j'avais envie de le dire
vous avez dit une autre fois peut-être
je ne vous cache pas qu'il y aura un
deuxième puis
chaque personne devra dire si ça
avait un doute sur qui avec quelqu'un
d'ici et du vivant
sur vous mais c'est pas droit parce que
c'est pas que négatif donc à celle là
oui ça un rapport écarté m non pas du
tout à quoi que ça pourrait finalement à
la longue d'accord
énigmatique mystérieuse je vous dis on
c'est spécial sera deuxième tour
au fra 2e non c'est certain je demande
au public est ce qu'on vous dit
[Applaudissements]
nick a prévu un énorme moi j'ai passé la
soirée c'est un chroniqueur un soir et
il m'a raconté un truc qui sait même pas
racontable si on ne raconte c'est assez
castaldi c'est foutu ccba j'ai encore
c'est moi mais c'est unique au monde ce
qui m'a raconté je ne l'avais jamais
entendu et je pense que je l'entendrai
de coach
ne les ai pas
j'adore et non jéricho pour ce premier
mondial faisait rien maintenant vous
m'avez halliche sy
savané déjà l'on peut pas le dire et
peut-être jeu j'essaierai de bois à ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on fait pas personne
n'a fait ça une déflagration
guillaume genton m'a dit quelque chose
je ne m'en remets toujours pas
c'est bien puis je pense que vous n'êtes
pas prêt c'est bien car un énorme
dossier sur raymond l'abominable homme
de rage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
me fait pas peur autant lui
les cherry hill à 18h58 et je pense
qu'il est temps de faire un tour de
taille
j'ai pas assez d'argent pour qu'on
puisse vous êtes vraiment sûr que moi je
fais partie du tour de table ou pas
enlever mamma mia j'ai une énorme
confiance en vous beinheim je suis
justement en train de faire votre
virement en direct
non mais c'est vrai voilà un ou entendu
je n'ai aucun problème avec vos beinheim
je suis droit avant je n'ai franchement
j'ai aucun problème ne cherchez pas à
l'acheter je vois votre terre alors
j'achète période je vous dire vous avez
un comme un conte
cali mona
s'il vous plaît castaldi non mais à
chaque fois vous direz on s'est fait je
le dis on c'est fait ou non je me tirais
à tout jamais il a été piégé allez on
enterre comme ça alors là là c'était sur
chivu sur gueugnon
france mais on pouvait vraiment pas
qu'il va faire comme c'est ma vie je
t'en supplie je travaille six qui s'y
trouvent
les faire un signe qui ne trompe pas
très équivoques très équivoque d'accord
je peux pas en dire un petit mot non non
non non un petit benjamin
la partie
ou balancer un dos ou août et à tout
jamais été à touche à tout jamais oui à
tous les toits jamais tout à fait lire
non pas
les ballons sa douce où vous vous taisez
à tout jamais
assez difficile sans réellement envie
mais
n'avait rien de soutien à les courageux
avec moi confie t on viendra thouars au
nom de notre
benhaim
[Rires]
fête
commencera une cagnotte valeritas cas
pas
avec toi
bref les chiffres sont remontés peur
mais attendons de cette tête de suspense
non mais non mais moi je fais aucune
tête vous regardez pas les
gens au nom de notre amitié indéfectible
cyril est plutôt au nom de mon compte en
banque
je ne dirai rien aulas non non on arrête
alors on s'est fait à la peine n'a cessé
de dire quand il y en a qui va balancer
tout le monde va super bien et je cours
je pense avoir de
bernard montiel série sur tous vos
travaux alors c'est dieu sur benji je le
rappelle parce que benji se plaint
toujours de vous balancer ça elle a
craqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce rendez vous gagnez
[Rires]
les
week-ends il existait pas je sais qu'en
janvier je sers france telle est
extraordinaire donc alors voila mon avis
avant janvier
alors calmez vous calmer
alors benji vous savez il fut souvent
une touche parce qu' il manque d'argent
ces pensions alimentaires tout le match
a hélas je peux vous dire aujourd'hui à
ce jour il va toucher des millions et
des millions très prochainement est un
malade mental
[Rires]
c'est l'histoire et l'histoire du procès
que j'allais gagner mais pas
de quoi tu parles je ne sais pas de quoi
tu parles il est en train de revendre
les droits de sa pièce très chère
mais celle ci est bon et puis alors avec
des superstars et puis la belle dose et
j'entends get outta leur rôle avec m
lundi si la demande et 20% à
l'écouté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais j'espère qu'il vous l'a dit parce
qu'il a rencontré aujourd'hui même à ce
sujet les dirigeants de canal+ non
j'espère qu'il vous l'a dit
de plus mme appellerons
est aujourd'hui monsieur saada grandir
bref c'est chaud
connard
cette séquence a promis des deux côtés
alors s il vous plaît pas c'est
ma passion c'est chaud alors mais non
mais c'est non c'est vrai j'ai vu
s'abattre au score c'est maxime saada
aujourd'hui ses souliers vernis c'était
un rendez vous prévu de longue date sera
finie que vous connaissez très bien qui
est le film que j'ai appris aux
prévisions et d'appeller peut-être que
j'en collision depuis très longtemps est
ce qu'il vous a dit articule et ta
gueule et
ses ressorts doubs s'est très bien passé
voilà ce qu'est ce qui vous a dit mais
ça s'est très bien passé ça s'est très
bien passé j'ai présenté mon projet
génération macérer louge la balance
[Applaudissements]
alors oui c'est très bien passé donc en
avant sur un sur un projet mais vous
allez me [ __ ]
oui
lol pour vous
c'est va passer grâce à alors gilles
tétouan main c'est pas un secret puisque
ces publics maintenant je fais non non
non mais je tenais ma conduite et non
malades et donc et donc vous avez fait
twh en supplie porté sur une pièce un
film une pièce et un fils louis avec
tiré de la pièce mais mais mais mais
commencé avec
des rendements à scarlett johansson et
le pauvre mais oui oui la tisza disant
eh ouais il est au courant de tout mais
oui mais oui les mêmes dans la boucle
ok bah
si c'est moi
c'est moi qui produit
génial voilà donc c'est des choses qui
avancent est vrai est donc à la wii mais
c'est bien que les gens de bosses
mais c'est vrai c'est génial mais ça j'y
crois à fond voilà donc donc l'on a
travaillé chez
[Rires]
vous le dire puisqu'ils ont tout
balancer de normal c'est vrai que si la
pièce va jusqu'au bout ce qui est fort
probable maintenant je pense que la
captation ira pour le groupe et n'a plus
voilà bien sûr voilà c'est important ce
qu on est en famille que j'ai proposé en
premier vous n'avez pas le faire sur
equidia que voilà voilà ça va tomber sur
l'âme ktb bah oui ça va passer sur un
plateau depuis six ans
les pièces fraîches ah oui bah j'ai vu
là des rapports fernand raynaud
elle est une ordure je perdais les
tuteurs
voilà merci en tout cas à bernard
montiel a tout déclenché dralha les
cherry
river novelli à vous avez un énorme
dossier sur raymond ouais ce que vous
décidez de le dire bien sûr si les
valeurs
à temps
c'est sous le regard des tauliers
castaldi cintrée non attends je suis ni
valérie c'est une tôle et de la télé à
la balance et un vent tiède c'est beau
mais
il a dit ma part sur france 2 est-ce que
famille ou entre amis c'est la hausse et
partir comme ça à droite à gauche et ma
famille cwi marché pour la cohésion du
groupe oui c'était sûrement regardé
généralement pour que tout se passe bien
mais dans un groupe oui il faut qu'on se
dise les choses j'aimerais et quand on
gardé secret c'est pas bon c'est pas
aller pour la transparence moi je suis
pour la transparence la transparence et
la cohésion du groupe transports est si
tu
mets la dans cette famille on vit nos
vies à côté on vit nos vies sur le
plateau et les bouleversantes
ne se raconter nos vrais vient mais fut
en dehors je t'attends pas sûr que ça
alors là tu en es livrer nos vies ça va
être très simple je vais demander
à illéla à morila
amauri ou oui à morila je vais demander
à maury de sortir quelques lives et dvd
du plateau quoi l'intimidation pas
d'intimidation elle est sortie du
plateau ils vont pas vous isolez
[Rires]
sur son téléphone et les concerts les
récents aucun contact avec le reste du
monde
voilà vous me sortez kelly b d'ovni
merci pas de regard raymond pas de
remarques à la turquie ni
on
va se retrouver dans un caddie vdev n'y
avait une révélation sur ce rémois bout
parce que ça crée mon amie kelly vdev 10
à l'isolément
elle revient de deux mois en thaïlande
vous lui a même pris son portable parce
que j'essaie de la joindre la haye
répond pas on est la plus portable avait
même posé les coupés du monde kelly b de
vélines on vous attend ce n'est pas tout
donné ramenez vous bordel à la casse
alors papa mais ramène toi allègre par
des pannes alors oui
merci
pourtant vous la racontez pas
rester
alors en même temps dans ce dossier
c'est le témoin vedette oui mais moi
j'ai fait un test pcr ce après midi ce
que j'ai la gorge qui pique et là je
suis positif on empêchera pas de faire
cela ça va aller très vite incapables
alors
je n'ai pas touché une pendule ce que
j'ai fait et j'ai hésité toute la pub
j'ai hésité tout jusqu'ici j'hésite
encore ce que vous avez reçu des
pressions qui est lives et dvd des
regards ainsi c'est un regard distant
oui vous avez peur du lendemain des gens
qui veulent le sauver des gens qui
veulent enfoncer et moi ce qui me plaît
pas c'est quand cette équipe je vais
alors je vous dire celle qui va prendre
la décision cette époque
je demande à isabelle
[Applaudissements]
isabelle dont condamnation qu'ils
appellent à ses biens services et la
partialité maaoui cette fidélité absolue
envers ordinaire on est ensemble depuis
le début c'est là la plus ancienne et
elle sera avec moi jusqu'au bout
isabelle vous voulez dire la musique est
ce que
vous voulez que kelly balance le dossier
sur raymond je n'ai qu'une chose à vous
dire avant de prendre votre temps pour
toi c'est à l'émission
vous remercie alors contrairement à tous
mes principes libéraux
alors vous savez à quel point raymond
qui dit m l'homme 10ème la femme
vraiment vous savez à quel point il est
fatigué le soir quand ils arrivent pour
l'émission et il se plaint il dit qu'il
a des longues journées et que c'est
compliqué la vie en ce moment et dont
les techniques alliées soit biolay y est
que jusqu alors si vous y allez quoi
faut y aller donc du coup je me suis
renseigné un petit peu sur sa vie comme
je me renseigne sur la vie de tout le
monde autour de cette table comme vous
savez et j'ai appris que le matin il
prenait son psy cam tard à 7 heures du
mat donc c'est l'heure à laquelle il
commence
je me suis rendu compte qu'ils se
réveillent à 5 heures et je me suis mis
c'est bizarre pourquoi tu te réveilles à
5 heures tu prends ton comme tard à
cette heure il ya deux heures
se maquiller quoi tu m'as parce qu'au
bout de sa foulée suis dit je vais un
petit peu inquiété et j'ai découvert
quelque chose donc ça mais à quel point
il aime les hommes donc du coup il aime
les femmes il aime l'être humain comme
je vous l'aï dit au début
et il existe des femmes
qui ont certains désirent voilà les
désirs de la vie des choses qu'on ne
contrôle pas qui se passe dans le
cerveau dans le coeur il ya des femmes
qui aiment certaines choses d'autres
d'autres
livres géraldine aime la musique il ya
des femmes qui aiment
se donner de l'importance est certes un
certain rapprochement physique que ce
soit avec l'homme mais là ce sont les
rapprochements physiques avec les
camions ah bon il ya des ya des femmes
comme beaucoup d'hommes parme thiem les
pieds il se frotte à des pieds mais il
ya des femmes qui se prend à des camions
je me sens pas comme vous savez à quel
point raymond
a besoin de subvenir aux besoins des
femmes
généralement ils se lèvent le matin et
voilà pourquoi il est fatigué quand il
ya des femmes qui se frotte sur son
camion
mais non égoutter qui dit camion dit
raymond
faites vos conclusions mais qui j'allais
goûter les attendait qui dit camion du
poët poët
j'ai compris en fait moi ouais c'est ce
qui est en train de dire canivez novelli
c'est qu'il y aurait des femmes qui vous
demandait de se frotter à votre camion
tenu serré que ça existe si c'est vrai
c'est déjà arrivé cd j'arrive déjà
arrivé mais alors là qu'on s'entend quoi
exactement ces barrettes frotte aux
camions
la femme est bien excité bas c'est lui
qui se frotte à l aube aux caméras
c'est à balles réelles je vais citer
dominique baudis baudis calomnie
quel l'omni international n'aime pas
c'est que vous attaquez s'est passé
madame b devenus si je sais pas ce qu'on
fait
s'il vous plaît c'est fou cette histoire
allait donc ça
ça arrive alors moi je n'ai pas vu on
m'a raconté ça arrive du côté du bois de
boulogne il se passe des trucs comme ça
avec les camions et à des femmes des
fois des femmes mi homme mi femme il se
frotte à des camions cette histoire est
vraie c'est pour ça que c'est un seynois
qu'elle allait raconter sa maman je ne
sais pas c est la première fois que j'ai
vu ça je voulais pas partir de bateaux
qu'on y est on y va phil montiel allé
par curiosité je voulais voir vraiment
si ça existait disent pas possible j'ai
parlé m'ont emmené mon camion dans le
bois de boulogne pour portes des femmes
se frotte sur mon camion effectivement à
la raison quad il ya des femmes qui se
frotte sur les camions dans le dans le
bois de boulogne la partie du camion ça
peut être l'avant comme ça peut être le
côté s'apprête à mais c'est pas
normalement c'est pas simplement le pot
d'échappement
qui vous plaît c'est bon
gros dossiers quand même ouais c'est pas
ouf
juste du gard époque
j'aimerais qu'elle reste au propre à
merci merci dingue cette rue gilles
verdez que vous avez un dossier sur
quelqu'un sur bernard montiel je suis à
votre disposition ou d'un quiz à valence
alors je garde c'est vous qui décidez
leur chef commence à nantes a balancé
pour nouvelles études et je vais vous
demander
guillaume jour tombe décider
c'est un grand oui
[Rires]
c
c'est magnifique sont des dehors
affables et sympathique est un homme
extrêmement stressé et a peur pour son
avenir jusque là ça va oui jeudi dernier
oui lorsque vous avez fait la table je
ne sais pas pour quelle raison vous avez
vos motivations vous n'avez pas mis
bernard montiel autour de la table oui
c'est vrai mais ce vendredi vous vouliez
le convoquer et il a prétexté qu'il
avait une occupation ailleurs un
tournage en angola eh bien c'est la
première partie de la révélation
pourquoi il n'est pas venu parce qu'il a
dit hanouna map après je dis fuck pour
le vendredi
la sienne vous ne pouvez pas démenti
alors je veux répondre je verrai pas
c'est vrai ouais ça vient d'un mot
qu'elle a c'est vrai ça c'est grave
c'est vrai j'avais aussi l'interview
dans un monde de rêve le croit gilles
verdez je vois ma fille nue et ça va
continuer comme cela
alors bernard montiel est donc
extrêmement stressé il sa peur c'est de
perdre sa place autour de la table et
pour la garder non ce nom qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire il faut écarter
d'autres moniker bien sûr comme moi
ouais il dit on sait jamais lui peut
être là je vais le bazar des exo
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bernard montiel
qu'est ce qu'il a fait hier volée
détournée des places de théâtre quoi
pour nous aimer ça mais vous savez quand
j'ai tissé escroquerie d'urcel
puisqu'après deux notions de
josiane balasko suiveux newey montiel me
regarde pas comme ça
j'irai jusqu'au bout aller jusqu'au bout
ou un chalet à gstaad de josiane balasko
que nous devions aller voir oui moi
j'avais prévu d'aller voir on avait deux
pièces j'y allais avec ma fille et puis
je dis donc je confirme que j'y vais
avec ma fille on m'appelle la production
très ennuyée gilles il ya un vrai
problème je sais pas si tu seras sur la
table du coup la semaine prochaine quand
balasko sera l'habitude n'ôte pas aller
alors le théâtre j'ai dit mais avec la
possible j'avais prévu avec ma fille
j'adore à l'asco je veux y aller je veux
y aller avec la petit montiel qui
n'avait qu'une place à exiger deux
places de théâtre en disant sinon je
fais un scandale je démonte la pièce de
théâtre vient pas à l'émission je ne
veux pas que vers d'eisai au théâtre je
prends les deux places et que verdès
dégage
[Applaudissements]
ces marges est certain que je peux
récent son réseau aux coupables mais
s'excentre raison ils profitent non
c'est faux ou pas profiter de profiter
du système c'était quoi oui j'ai appelé
josiane balasko direct qui m'a donné les
places dimanche avec une maladresse
deuxième soirée passée la mienne
je suis pas passée par là merci gilles
verdez et c'est faux non c'est vrai
c'est que c'est vrai tous étaient
balancés ici c'est vrai et gilles verdez
c'est toujours des enquêtes extrêmement
sérieux isabelle morini-bosc vous avez
oublié vous
dire j'ai oublié qua non non je vais
dire 0 005 % de ce que de ce qui m'a été
dit j'ai été toujours par quelqu'un du
futur groupe tf1 m6 et qui m'a dit comme
en cent ans cyril hanouna avec bolloré
en ce moment on a entendu dire que il y
avait deux trois petites disputes parce
que les ennemis d'hier sont les amis de
demain et série nous intéresse toujours
voilà donc à quoi je me tais pas
d'action dans la maison à mais en
revanche on répondre je vous répondre ça
en revanche ça c'est faux on se retourne
très très bien ce qui s'est passé le
parti qui m'intéressent la lan party qui
m'intéresse et c'est la suite mais c'est
ma femme il y aura serena noon après
demain ou après demain je serai chez moi
si je pouvais pas dire
non non non ça se passe très très bien
avec les jeux c'est vraiment et il n'y a
aucun problème oui ou pas ok c'est pas
ça empêche pas que les autres
s'intéresse à vous on peut bien sûr bah
oui mais la belle espèce de truc qui
plane chez rtl m6 était beatles jusque
là bas faut pas dire ton nom trois fois
ils ont toujours peur tu débarques dans
les adore
c'est vrai adore ce goût non mais c'est
vrai que j'aime beaucoup ce groupe c'est
la vie et ses variétés oui c'est vrai
que je m'entends bien est ce là bas
pourquoi à moi
je vous avais ras contre quoi il arrive
ça oui question qui est super c'est
qu'on a entendu parce que je voulais
aller faire son sort et la chance c'est
bien oui mais voilà c'était pourtant
mais j'ai passé deux ans merveilleux là
va faire très bien avec eux bah oui ça
s'est passé quoi beetlejuice ecost
histoire mais il ya débat il y avait des
bruits à chaque fois au moment où que
alors je dis tout après tu pensé mais
moi je commence à en avoir assez
sont pas au devant de gros problèmes non
mais quand il y avait une rumeur de
canal qui doit racheter m6 yaman
histoires comme ça que c'est vrai ou pas
dis moi si c'est vrai la suite je dis
moi si c'est vrai ou pas que à un moment
donné m6 et canal avant de tf1 arrive
c'était canal c'était le groupe bolloré
voilà propose il y avait des
propositions et tout le monde disait il
faut faire attention ce qu'on n'est pas
à l'abri cadenas débarque donc il faut
se tenir tranquille rien n'avait certain
qu'il redoutait et d'autres qui le
souhaitaient bien sûr on est d'accord la
mairie que ça nous a rapprochés
c'est très bien alors je disais des
conneries et la domaine alors est-ce que
vous avez c'est sûr qu'ils turquie n'est
pas ce que j'ai pour tout le monde à oui
c'est vrai benjamin castaldi
mais bon mais alors j'ai aussi sur base
à choisir de ne pas le dire en fait
voilà j'ai une grosse boule qui sur
benjamin mais le problème c'est que je
me dise ça peut peut-être que ça se fait
pas de le dire et moi je suis un soldat
je balance pas comme alors je vais
demander à une tierce personne de vous
donner l'aval ou pas pour que vous
donniez cette pique je vais demander à
bernard madoff
ne fais pas le con sen truqués centre
social ça c'est gros
gros le site attenant au contraire
libérer une place
vasella
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais alors vraiment alors vraiment pas
leur temps et d'argent il peut pas dire
si moi je peux le dire ou pas tu peux
pas te donne un salaire tu peux me
donner un feu vert est hissé de
week-end en week-end aux etats-unis
allaient maintenant on a été trop loin
et par respect aux portes et spectateurs
on va le dire
[Rires]
je sais qui
je m'en fous je ne venais pas l'histoire
sur l'autre aidé à l'époque il avait
mérité son argent il m'avait raconté une
fois benjamin qui était parti en
week-end aux etats-unis je crois le sens
las vegas prendre comme ça ça tout ça
derrière las vegas est en fait il a joué
au casino aidé à gagner une énorme somme
d'argent
monaco monaco c'était
monaco et il a gagné une énorme somme
d'argent et cette énorme somme d'argent
et dak lak et en un week-end en un week
end cercle vert a
touché une somme d'argent le dimanche à
n'y avait plus rien
ok nous n en veut pas savoir combien
de pas savoir combien d'équipés dans ces
faits n'a là c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux
m son train de vie de l'époque il ya 15
ans c'était il ya 15 ans avec 100 trains
de ceux contraints de vie c'est de
l'argent qui tombait du ciel comme idi
il a voulu faire plaisir à tout le monde
et il a lâché en à peine une semaine
sept cent cinquante mille euros
je voulais c'est alors je
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
m'attends à l'époque non non non c'est
non mais il est moche ça
m'impressionnait caché qu'il était
couple oui qui regrette un petit peu
tout ça qui m'a aidé à me joindre mais
c'était vous savez il ya des il ya un
livre que tu connais xv est le joueur le
saut à skis ce qui est très bien
effectivement ce soir là je ne sais pas
ce qui s'est passé j'ai tout ce que je
mettais sur le tapis tout ce que je
mettais sa rentrée ça avant mais j'ai
vécu un truc de fou et j'ai gagné c'est
vrai 750000 euros et 45 en quoi tu la
dépense et 750 et déjà pour jouer 750 ne
jouais pas 5 balla gaye 2 malgré des
accueils poussée que j'ai vu ce qu un
art mocca déloger eu le fameux voile
noir et dont fermer la table et plus
largement à quai sera donc ils ont fermé
la taille de l'exécuter nous attend on
va on vous paye et il faut arriver avec
des talbins comme ça des billets de 500
ballons n'ai jamais vu autant de ma vie
est comme ça et j'ai ma place j'ai mis
tout ça semble sombre
jeter dedans
et j'étais avec des copains et j'étais
avec jean-philippe que vous connaissez
j'avais été plein de copains et on a
fait on a fait une semaine voilà on a
fait n'importe quoi et voilà bon j'étais
jeune on ma famille d'abord fait ça
exceptionnellement
vraiment exceptionnel d'avoir invité
était une somme colossale
mais
également dans toute une ville
pouvait régaler les copains s'en aller
cet énorme comme un cul du kgb
by coûté en tout cas voulait bien foutu
dans la merde et vas-y tu peux le dire
d'accord je réponds tu m'as fait mais
j'ai dit comme
tout bête plata estivaux sont derrière
ce que voulait le dire
et surtout une pub de 38 cents à l'aide
sociale a dit un peu parce que après le
pare-chocs de raymond ça a été un peu
chaud et là c'est pire mais la donne au
pire que
ça m'a surpris j'ai trouvé ça très très
étonnant
code camion nantes a pas de camions on
en
tue c'est juste une question vous êtes
vous êtes de vos enfants
je suis fier de vous merci où vous êtes
resté front à et vous avez gardé votre
franchise maintenant je ne sais pas si
vous avez gardé votre travail
c'est important de savoir que vous avez
gardé votre franchise géraldine oui j'ai
fait quelque chose que je ne fais jamais
très bien
mais tu es gay oj antoine isolement
[Applaudissements]
une personne a été mise en isolement on
ne peut pas
faire
de pression géraldine maillet qu'il ya
des révélations sur lui cette personne à
l'iso le banc c'est guillaume genton on
va lui demander de venir guy lux si tu
peux venir
merci guy
guérin ne l'aviez vous aviez une
révélation ah ben c'est sûr guillaume
genton dit là maintenant ou taisez vous
à tout jamais je peux encore me taire a
touché au ballon ça se passe à table je
vais demander à quelqu'un de dire s'il
doit non mais vous avez pas normal en
fait de veiller à lui demander quand
même si vous devez le dire ou pas à
gilles verdez alors
[Applaudissements]
à l'avarié gilbert décès la famille
alors d'abord j'adore guillaume
ne sais pas évidemment que je ne le juge
pas et au contraire j'étais très très
touché qu'il se livre à moi avec autant
franchise de la bière il ya bien
après au mieux il est très très flippant
alors alors guillaume a une fascination
il est très très très attiré par
une sorte de film
pas tu m'as dit bobo vos bouts est ce
que vous connaissez les films les
chimères
[Rires]
ont fêté des deux en un ça ce sont des
femmes hommes et des femmes avec des
comores m certes elle dit des poitrines
de femmes et le sexe d'homme musées en
fête
a tourné talonne répondent à ces
élections on passera plus jamais une
soirée
tombé du nid un deuxième effet qu'ils
soient d'accord parce que quand il m'a
dit ça d'abord je sais très bien et
pourtant voilà mais
benjamin castaldi et à côté il a dit oui
moi aussi je quitte sa
saison
je sais
c'est leur droit l'alliance à ce que je
vois oui c'est que il ya des vraies
révélations
je vous réponds quand on sait que c'est
vrai la famille externe de shimell en
fait on parlait musique elle m'a dit
qu'elle est à chanteuse préférée g10 et
chimène badi gmail gmail gmail m'a dit
voilà elle a mal compris et de la
benjamin j'attendais ce jour c'est vrai
d'accord a très bien de dire les choses
et on remercie aucun progrès jradi my
hand